une petite semaine après le lancement de
la vaccination pour les personnes de 75
ans et plus les premiers couacs se font
donc ressentir en indre et loire les
cinq centres de vaccination affichent
tous complets même constat du côté des
trois centres ouverts en loir-et-cher
pour tenter de comprendre cette
situation ont fait le point avec notre
invité du jour christophe l'union
bonjour bonsoir vous êtes donc le
responsable du service communication à
la rs du centre val de loire c'est donc
l'agencé régionale de santé qui chapote
toute l'organisation de cette
vaccination
à l'heure actuelle combien personnes de
plus de 75 ans se sont fait vacciner
depuis le début de la semaine dans nos
départements
alors depuis le début de la semaine on
constate en effet très nettement une
forte une très très forte appétence à la
vaccination dans notre région cerveau
pour l'indre et loire et le blanchir
mais pour l'ensemble de la région
et ça vaut pour l'ensemble des
territoires de france
en indre et loire on est un peu plus de
1000 avec les chiffres d'aujourd'hui que
je n'ai pas dépassé les 1000 et on leur
est cher un peu plus de 500 pour les
personnes âgées de plus de 75 ans est en
effet on constate que je n'entende dans
votre reportage
la dame qui a parlé mais de même que le
maire d'amboise
on constate que les gens n'arrivent plus
à prendre des rendez vous parce que les
plannings sont complets donc je pense
qu'on va y venir c'est plus qu'un couac
moi je prendrais pas d'un couac en fait
pas du tout en quoi que c'est une
organisation difficile à mettre en place
en fonction des doses disponibles de
vaccins dont pourquoi est-ce-que
pourquoi est-ce que c'est difficile est
ce que justement vous avez surestimé le
nombre de doses disponibles et qu'il n'y
en a plus est ce qu'il ya eu trop de
demande c'est quoi le problème le le
fêter c'est bien celui que je viens de
dire c'est à dire que l'appétence pour
la vaccination en soi d'ailleurs c'est
très très bien en termes de prévention
et de santé publique que les gens se
décident à se faire vacciner c'est
parfait il s'avère qu'on a eu énormément
de demandes joue même un chiffre oui le
premier jour de la mise en place de la
plate forme régionale qu'on a donc vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure
plus de 145 mille personnes ont appelé
cette plateforme au niveau régional il
est évident qu'on ne pouvait pas calé
145000 rendez-vous dans les premiers
jours donc c'est un problème que de plus
en plus de gens veulent prendre des
rendez vous et c'est normal on ne peut
pas répondre tout de suite dans un
premier temps à toutes les demandes
pourtant est ailleurs c'est à dire que
faut bien que les gens comprennent et je
pense que les tourangeaux comme les
habitants du loir et cher le comprennent
tout le monde pourra se faire vacciner
toutes celles et ceux qui souhaitent se
faire vacciner
le pourront dans les semaines à venir la
course de fond dont on a évoqué le
gouvernement c'est tout à fait ça c'est
une campagne de vaccination qui donnera
plusieurs semaines et les plus de 75 ans
les personnes qui ont différentes
pathologies
on comprend tout à fait leur volonté de
se faire vacciner parce qu'elles savent
que éventuellement elles peuvent avoir
une forme grave de la commune et c'est
aussi pour cela que la priorisation
c'est fait pour ces personnes depuis
maintenant donc le début de la semaine
dernière finalement vous avez été
victime de votre succès vous n'attendiez
pas un petit singe comme si la demande
de la jeune âge eux directement victimes
de notre succès d'un couac parce que
c'est pas un couac en soit on vaccine de
plus en tête deux fois ci c'est
exactement c'est très positif on vaccine
de plus en plus de personnes et ça c'est
très bien
on comprend et tout le monde peut
comprendre la volonté que les gens ont
vraiment de se faire vacciner donc c'est
c'est vraiment compréhensible on ne peut
pas les rencontrer
maintenant que la nouvelle d'un vaccin
au parlement on a les doses qu'on devait
être content de t'avoir et toutes les
semaines il y aura des fournitures de
doses telles qu'elles sont envisagées
les centres de vaccination doivent être
calibré en fonction des doses dont nous
disposons et on est par ailleurs ça nous
n'avons pas parlé mais contraint pour
cette première phase de campagne par la
logistique que le vaccin de pfizer et
nécessitent c'est à dire la conservation
avec ma 80 - 90 c'était moi donc
évidemment quand nous aurons d'autres
vaccins le moderna deviendra un très
prochainement d'astrazeneca dans
quelques semaines également
on y verra on est on aura une vraie
bouffée d'oxygène le fait est
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons trailer qui
intervient qui arrive un de tiger woods
notamment avec son son annonce qu'ils
ont donc ils ont fait récemment qu'ils
vont augmenter leurs capacités de
production et pour augmenter leurs
capacités de votre production il fonde
en salle des travées et donc ces voix là
mais il faut bien comprendre que
l'impatience des détours en jambes et
d'inconscience de l'ancien de la
population est tout à fait
compréhensible
un grand homme d'état lisez vous savez
ma patience effet 2001 patience donc
faut tout cette ses impatiences de de
cette population forment une grande
patience et chacun encore une fois que
pourra se faire vacciner là et pour
concrètes sur un point il n'y aura pas
d'annulations il peut y avoir ici ou là
des déprogrammations mais qui sont donc
des reports parce que l'objectif c'est
bel et bien de d'avoir des rendez-vous
qui sont fixés qui seront pris et
l'objectif c'est une fois que vous avez
votre première dose d'avoir la deuxième
succès indispensable
quatre nouveaux centres de doivent
s'ouvrir la semaine prochaine en loir et
cher à saint-aignan à contre à saint
georges sur cher à lamotte beuvron un
nouveau centre doit également ouvrir en
indre et loire à loches
est ce que dans ce contexte elles vont
ouvrir ou pas oui alors l'important
c'est qu'il faut lundi coeur sur le site
de l' agence régionale de santé à toutes
les informations seront données y
compris sur 6 des préfectures qui les
communications se font trois des centres
la vallée du cher dont vous allez parler
tourneront donc les intervenants par
rotation pour justement permettre à tout
un chacun de pouvoir y aller il ya des
centres qui fonctionne tous les jours et
d'autre on va adapter la voilure en
fonction des doses et c'est très
important et c'est très important aussi
de dire que toute cette organisation
c'est les services de l'état la rs la
préfecture les collectivités
territoriales qui ont joué un rôle
majeur dans la mise en place de ces
centres on est à tous le salue
l'engagement du président du conseil
départemental les médecins libéraux
parce que sans médecins ont fait pas
fonctionner les centres faut des
médecins des infirmiers et notamment si
les pompiers parce que les services
d'importance à ces mais c'est vraiment
tous les partenaires qui sont investis
au jour le jour pour que cette campagne
d'action aux 6es elle réussira on va
écouter merci merci entre entre d'être
venu rassurer en tout cas les personnes
de plus de 75 ans ils pourront donc se
faire vacciner on l'aura compris même
fleurir sur mignot